[Musique]
cette journée internationale du droit
des femmes nous commençons cette
émission par un grand merci merci aux
infirmières aux médecins aux aides
soignantes aux agents d'entretien aide
ménagère aide à domicile à celle qui
tous les jours se plie en quatre pour
soigner leurs patients
elles sont nombreuses par partout dans
le monde les femmes représentent 70 %
des ressources humaines en santé on
tenait vraiment aujourd'hui à leur
rendre hommage
regarde moi bien nous détourne pas le
regard
regarde moi bien quand je suis en
première ligne regarde moi bien quand je
dis non regarde moi bien quand je refuse
de tout gérer chez nous regarde moi bien
quand je demande un salaire égal
à cette occasion le gouvernement lance
l'opération 1000 possible et publient
sans lettres écrites par des
personnalités féminines à l'attention
des mille petites filles qui vont naître
celui mars 2021
tu pourrais devenir présidente de la
république ou la première personne à
marcher sur mars
cette année le visage d'une figure
méconnue de l'histoire revient à de
nombreuses reprises
clara zetkin était une militante
féministe allemande c'est elle qui est à
l'origine de cette journée il y à 110
ans mesdames soyez les bienvenus
aujourd'hui 8 mars journée des droits de
la femme et pas journée de la femme que
je pourrais y aurait une journée laval
jouer des droits de la femme
donc je j'assume totalement l'idée de
vous offrir des fleurs si ça ne vous
convient pas ne les prenais pas parce
qu'il ya des filles qui trouvent ça
réducteur de d'offrir des fleurs à des
filles donc fait exactement comme vous
voudrez vous les prenez ces jolies sinon
vous méprenez pas
mm
ici la bagasse de l'eau
vous le savez peut-être c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
qu'est ce qui est prévu pour améliorer
leur représentativité
alors à l'occasion les députés de la
majorité ont déposé aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi pour accélérer
l'égalité économique et professionnelle
entre les hommes et les femmes le texte
prévoit notamment d'instaurer des quotas
pour renforcer la présence des femmes
dans les postes à hautes responsabilités
les postions où il y a du pouvoir dans
les entreprises de plus de 1000
personnes
il ya des droits annoncé qu'ils le sont
pas la parité jeudi la saisie a été de
salaire et la soi-disant et c'est pas le
cas si vous gagnez si vous gagnez vous
aujourd'hui vous avez 25 % de moins que
c'est le champion gagne voyez s'est
évidemment dit comme ça ça fait rire la
réplique la plus biatch entendu d'un
monde du cinéma en parlant d'une actrice
un acteur avait dit elle n'est pas assez
belle pour jouer aussi mal et c'est
chiant je peux pas donner les noms
alors c'est la journée des droits de la
femme et je voulais qu'on commence par
une image qui peut être vous choquer et
en tout cas vous interpellez puisqu'un
clitoris kg en rouge immanquable a été
placé sur précisément sur la place du
trocadéro pendant quelques heures ce
lundi matin une version géante et
gonflable de cet organe était installé à
paris pour célébrer cette journée
internationale des droits de la femme
c'est important de rappeler cette
journée on vous avez beaucoup une bonne
fin une bonne fête des femmes
aujourd'hui je lis cayenne pas le nom
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui offre
des roseaux des chocolats et les qui
sauvent taxer le jour des droits des
femmes est pas la journée des femmes oui
faut le rappeler on ne veut pas des
dessous affriolants
bah oui encore il ya encore des et
encore des soutiens gorge on veut
l'égalité salariale
exactement
attends tu peux te tourner et j'ai vu un
truc je crois il a vu caen
même quand je vois des jeunes filles
comme ça j'ai envie de te prendre un
gros manteau et les couvrir
comment faire un régime j'ai jamais fait
de régime de ma vie et j'ai attaqué un
peu jashari un peu c'est parce que
j'entends c'est pour son bien quoi pour
pas que genre son futur mari disait
vous mais genre je dis ça pour qu'elle
soit vraiment parfaite parfaite aucun
défaut j'aimerais qu'il y ait une
journée du droit des hommes ce soir le
jour des faits c'est contraire à
l'égalité salariale n'a pas l'égalité
cela l'essentiel
non on va aller dans cette action à 6 cm
écouter mais les femmes ont gagné depuis
depuis maintenant 10 ans 20 ans nous
l'apprend aujourd'hui dans une société
matriarcale les hommes c'est face les
hommes n'osent même plus à endiguer
comme étant des hommes je voudrais je
récupère une journée des hommes 30 pont
30 bon bus tzen 90,0 j'ai alors attends
on va commencer
1 les hommes se maquille de plus en plus
mais où il ya pauline tendances venues
de grande-bretagne et des etats-unis si
l'on en croit cette enquête du guardian
les marques de cosmétiques observe une
très nette augmentation des ventes des
produits destinés aux hommes une hausse
qu'on explique par le temps passé sur
zoom et sur skype les professionnels
parlent d'un effet zoom avec notamment
une hausse des ventes de fond de teint
pour les hommes en face de moi
mais là tu vois
voyez vous si j'étais pas mariée je
pense que j'aurais pu prendre la place
de ma fille
[Applaudissements]
il est très mignon je sais pas je sais
pas si je sais pas sur un texte d'accord
alors il ya plein de gens qui lisent
qu'est ce qu'on s'en bat l'oeil de la
dernire moyens non mais non mais alors
parce que ça intéresse de fou et et moi
personnellement mais je m'en bat femmes
chin with you about ses forces et ça ils
ont 35 vraiment séparer la compétition
monte cristo la cemac à 20 millions est
venu chercher
mais c'est bon là et où est ce que je me
plaindre à la témoin ils ont entendu ni
barack à fabas et il vient de faire
chier le monde non mais ouvert alors oui
c'est quoi laisser passer ça je suis
quand même très très frappé bras chaque
fois par la démonstration d'unité autour
d'une chose qui peut nous paraître
effectivement dans d'accord si c'est pas
intéressant ce que nous dit gay elle
marie billa n'en ai pas peur et on s'est
alors d'abord écouté wifi désolé si ce
que je dis n'est pas intéressant non pas
dire de nom mais je vais dire ce que je
dis vous voulez tous parlé sur un truc
voilà enfin des citoyens turcs aussi bon
dos notre envie de révolte
j'ai envie de crier dessus plus ça va
pas
à chaque fois que j'ouvre la bouche vous
dit que c'est pas intéressant prix alors
non mais là j'en ai ma maison jour du
siam les boules mais j'aime ce club la
part de courir et goûter plane comme
tout maintenir toujours vais vous dire
si vous voulez pas m'entendre je me
barre mais c'est toujours la maison ça
suffit maintenant vous disent que ce que
j'ai pas intéressante et nous embête
pour vous d'accord va partir